[Musique]
première journée de travail du service
de la coopération à maurice à quelques
jours du conseil des ministres de la
commission de l'océan indien
après un premier contact avec les agents
de l'ambassade de france
direction le ministère de l'éducation
mauricien
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés ce qu'à mi-chemin de
tirer pour le premier gros parce que à
passer de la bride nous aurons quand
même à notre groupe qui va rejoindre et
on attendait avec collaboration avec des
extraits de la réunion au peut nous
offrir des capacités pour faire la
formation de femmes au niveau primaire
secondaire
ce projet structurant de formation
d'enseignants en charge d'enfants
handicapés a démarré à madagascar
aujourd'hui le département soutient
financièrement cette initiative portée
par le cep centre international d'études
pédagogiques
un jour je l'espère la possibilité de
faire une partie d'une classe
la réunion de la même année l'autre
partie de la classe dans un pays de la
zone saint dié et d'avoir la
reconnaissance de diplômes de l'année ou
de l'année en cours
quel que soit le lieu où on aura fait la
classe c le sujet le faut il ya des
spécificités qu'il faudra dix en tête et
puis travailler là dessus et surtout
chatou que jeudi qu' il faut pas créer
là où il faut quand même essayer
d'apprendre et prendre ce qui a été créé
et bouger plus de rang vous croyez donc
gagnant gagnant oui définitivement
c'est parce que nous avons quand même
des acquis qui vont était présent et
qu'on pourrait échanger pas seulement
pour la région mais aussi francophone et
dans l'océan indien
le champ de l'handicapé clairement les
expertises du département en fin de
journée la rencontre avec l'ambassadeur
de france à maurice confirme l'utilité
de cette action
cofinancé par l'union européenne une
réciprocité qui permet d'avancer dans
cette communauté de destin india
océanique nous avons pu identifier des
projets très concrets
justement agricole dans le domaine aussi
de de la culture domaine de l'éducation
dans le domaine de l'eau et je pense que
ce sombre par ces projets concrets qu'on
peut entre
maurice et la france réunion justement
avancer et nous permettre d'échanger
progresser ensemble le protocole passé
les discussions deviennent rapidement
passionnant par un échange d'expériences
à quelques jours du conseil des
ministres de la coi ses poignées de
mains et ses regards croisés font toute
la différence
la coopération est un acteur qui a un
bus c'est aussi aujourd'hui une mise en
commun des besoins alors cette
coopération est gagnant-gagnant
volontaire elle permettra un réunionnais
d'aller à maurice mais elle permettra un
mauricien aussi de vouloir comprendre on
à apprendre à maurice et maurice à
apprendre aussi on est dans cette
approche cas d'évasion
[Musique]